[Música]
eu sabia que 87% dos trabalhadores do
mundo eles estão dentro de empresas
privadas e que das 100 principais
entidades econômicas do planeta 69 estão
empresas e só 31 são países
já pensou se as empresas usassem o
máximo possível dos seus recursos e
conhecimento para melhorar a situação do
mundo
a gente não pode ignorar a importância
que as empresas têm para gerar impacto
social e por isso reúne quatro coisas
para falar para as empresas que querem
gerar um impacto de uma forma verdadeira
e genuína mas falar sobre eles faz
sentido a gente voltar um pouco na
história entender o contexto de como que
começou essa relação empresa impacto da
revolução industrial as empresas elas
eram vistas como que em geral com os
problemas sociais nem tão existe uma
carga horária de trabalho absurda tinha
muita pobreza muito trabalho infantil
e aí foi nesse contexto que as empresas
começaram a falar sobre condições
mínimas de trabalho e começar a fornecer
por nesse almoço para os funcionários
um espaço para recreação e até acesso
aos hospitais a década de 20 foi um
período que o poder ele ficou muito
concentrado na mão de poucas empresas o
que acabou gerando um desequilíbrio com
as outras partes da sociedade
e aí vem a crise de 29 altos índices de
desemprego os negócios começaram a
fechar ea sociedade precisa pensar de
uma nova forma de se reerguer de
estabelecer relações
foi aí que as empresas a comunidade e os
funcionários começaram a se relacionar
de uma forma mais equilibrada
foi aí também que a filantropia ela
entrou muito forte para dentro das
empresas nem tão os proprietários
eles decidiram destinar um valor
específico para a caridade
então normalmente ia para a construção
de um hospital ou uma creche em 1990
aí foi um período de globalização as
empresas muito preocupados com a
reputação como elas seriam vistas pelo
mundo teve uma necessidade muito grande
de se falar o que estava sendo feito
então em alguns casos as empresas
colocaram um cargo específico para
marketing ligado às causas sociais
em outros casos as empresas elas
internalizaram a responsabilidade social
no dna e alinharam com os objetivos
estratégicos e aí tiver o caso de
empresas que cresceram por terem adotado
práticas de responsabilidade social e
até um caso que é muito conhecido é de
emprego decresceu por um dos fatores de
texto e olhar para a responsabilidade
social foi a belém gere ela é uma
empresa americana de sorvete e ela
coloca pessoas num patamar muito
importante dentro da empresa então desde
o fornecedor do leite para fazer o
sorvete eles tenham cuidado até o
cliente final
então a sociedade começa a enxergar a
empresa com uma confiança maior
e é isso foi uma das coisas que
colaborou com o crescimento deles
se a gente for lá esse recorte histórico
de responsabilidade social começou
oferecendo condições mínimas de trabalho
aí veio a filantropia ea caridade e aí a
responsabilidade social ela entrou para
dentro das empresas
em alguns casos para marketing em outros
casos alinhado com o objetivo
estratégico e hoje a sociedade exige
cada vez mais que as empresas tenham um
propósito social claro que o que começou
como um mínimo exigido virou um
diferencial e hoje é fundamental para a
sobrevivência dos negócios as empresas
por muito tempo elas foram vistas como
vilãs né porque ela gerava um impacto
muito negativo
ou então por oportunistas por que elas
usavam das causas para marketing
mas a gente não pode esquecer que de
fato tem algumas lideranças preocupadas
em como gerar impacto de uma forma
verdadeira dentro das empresas
e aí vem uma pergunta como que as
empresas podem de fato gerar impacto
social positivo sem que isso seja uma
questão de marketing ou de visibilidade
e algumas empresas já fizeram já
mostraram alguns caminhos pra isso e por
isso reunir 64 pontos para mostrar para
as empresas que querem gerar esse
impacto de uma forma verdadeira e
genuína 1
isso tem que se tornar uma prioridade
dentro da empresa
o evolucionário ele é o fundador da
patagônia que é uma empresa americana de
roupas para atividades ao ar livre e ele
escreveu um livro chama empresas
responsáveis que ele conta todos os
aprendizados que ele teve ao longo dessa
trajetória da patagônia quando eles
resolveram firmar o impacto social como
a prioridade lá dentro o que ele fez ele
falou eu quero entender aonde que eu
gera um impacto mais negativo em toda a
minha linha de produção e aí ele definiu
que não farei sozinho então ele envolveu
a empresa como um todo para comprar essa
briga com ele lá dentro quando todo
mundo olhou pra esse objetivo único eles
conseguiram chegar a um resultado e
viram que o algodão era o que mais
gerava um impacto negativo na natureza
e aí eles resolveram que a partir de
então toda a produção seria feito com
algodão 100% orgânico e aí por ele ter
conseguido alinhar toda essa força
interna trabalhando para o mesmo
objetivo em só 18 meses eles conseguiram
transformar toda a produção e desde
então eles continuam firmes e fortes na
missão de gerar o menor impacto na
natureza
quando a responsabilidade social é uma
prioridade compartilhada com todo mundo
é quando nascem os negócios como
propósito na essência
a segunda o segundo ponto é que quando
as atividades de impacto social
elas são alinhadas com o objetivo
estratégico de negócio e isso tem de
acontecer de uma forma muito mais rápida
e efetiva
já pararam para pensar o impacto que a
inteligência artificial tem para
resolver os desafios sociais quando se o
da ibm fala nossa responsabilidade
social reflete o nosso negócio ele se
compromete de forma verdadeira a usar
todo o conhecimento que é toda a equipe
tem pra levar tecnologia e inovação para
jovens iniciativas sociais tanto que
hoje ele tem um programa que chama petek
que leva é que treina jovens para saber
da possibilidade do futuro usando a
inteligência artificial
então quando a empresa linha objetivos
de negócio com o objetivo de impacto
isso tem de acontecer mais rápido porque
um conhecimento que ela já tem o
terceiro ponto é a responsabilidade
social sair do papel precisa ter uma
energia interna exclusiva para fazer
isso acontecer e quando falei nem
internas pode ser uma pessoa pode ser
uma área pode até o instituto uma
fundação a isso depende do contexto de
cada empresa
o caso da ambev foi muito interessante
porque quando eles criaram voa que é um
programa para levar a gestão ambev para
dentro das iniciativas sociais
ele começou com uma pessoa tocando em
paralelo com as atividades do dia a dia
que não era uma de impacto social
quando essa pessoa ela ficou 100%
responsável pelo programa o nível de
impacto subiu muito e eles conseguiram
importar mais de 100 11 em todo o brasil
então quando a responsabilidade social
ela não acontece em paralelo existe uma
força interna exclusiva para fazer isso
faz muita diferença
o quarto ponto é o seguinte é sobre o
comprometimento da liderança
a verdade é que nada vai sair do papel
se a liderança não estiver comprometida
e junto nessa briga de gerar um impacto
social
assim os force ela é uma empresa de
software americano e ela lidera vários
movimentos de responsabilidade social
corporativa e existe um novo um dos mais
conhecidos hoje chama comprometam 1%
o nome é muito mais conhecido em inglês
que é prédio amplo senti que eles falam
o seguinte você empresa olha pra dentro
e ver o que você consegue se comprometer
pode ser que consiga comprometer um por
cento do tempo dos seus funcionários
ótimo legal vamos juntar fazer um dia do
voluntariado sá todo esse conhecimento
interno para gerar uma transformação
real na sociedade ou pode ser que se
consiga comprometer um por cento do seu
produto tem gente de vários produtos e
serviços que a empresa oferece que não
que oferecem que não têm acesso a esses
produtos e serviços então por que não
oferecer um por cento para quem hoje não
têm oportunidade de ter acesso a eles
pode ser também que se queira desde não
por cento da sua receita
então vou deixar um pouco a minha
receita porque eu vou investir em algum
negócio em alguma causa que eu acredito
que está alinhado como objetivo
estratégico e aí assim gerando o exemplo
da liderança de realmente se comprometeu
em geral impacto de uma forma verdadeira
e que hoje esse movimento está empresa
em mais de 100 países do mundo todo
a gente tem mania de colocar a
responsabilidade social na mão das
grandes empresas já têm certa
estabilidade já tem recurso então foi
grande empresa sua responsabilidade de
resolver os desafios globais
mas isso não é tão falado aqui mas mais
de 96% das empresas no brasil são de
pequeno e médio porte e esse número nos
estados unidos é de não mais de 99%
então se imaginam a força que as
pequenas e médias empresas têm prazer a
uma transformação positiva no mundo
eu hoje trabalha em uma empresa em
crescimento não é uma breve não é o bbm
mas eu acredito muito que as empresas
elas são a gente muito importante para
acelerar a transformação social e para
fazer isso qualquer empresa de qualquer
porte para começar
precisa colocar isso como uma prioridade
a linha o objetivo de impacto com o
objetivo estratégico tem uma energia
interna exclusiva para fazer isso
acontecer ea liderança precisa comprar
essa briga com todo o coração
aí sim vocês imaginam se a gente
consegue unir as pequenas e as médias e
as grandes empresas para criar um mundo
que sonhamos
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]